At the end of Game of Thrones season 8 we
are left bitter and dissapointed with Bran
Satrk,
this Three Eyed Raven, becoming the new King
of Westeros
and now we have a revelation coming from none
other than the Game of Thrones showrunners,
David Benioff and Dan Weiss, that the books
will end the same.
Speaking in the audio commentary of the season
8 episode 6 that for some reason is the only
commentary episode that didn't air on the
Game of Thrones official YouTube channel,
a behind-the-scenes look at filming the finale,
showrunners David Benioff and D.B Weiss dropped
some huge news about the books.
The showrunners confirm Bran being named king
of Westeros
is author George R.R. Martin’s planned ending
for his the „A Song of Ice and Fire“ novels.
They said that the ending will be the same,
Bran Stark will be the King,
claiming that George RR Martin revealed it
to them,
and ultimately that is why Bran ended up on
the throne at the very end of the show.
George
RR Martin himself had this to say about the
endings of both the show and the books.
''How will it all end?
I hear people asking.
The same ending as the show?
Different?
Well… yes.
And no.
And yes.
And yes.''
Martin then proceeds to make three points:
- D&D only had 8 hours for the final season,
but he'll have more space.
- There's the butterfly effect, with changes
from past seasons affecting this one.
- There are lots of characters in the books
who never made it to the show,
so that changes the entire storyline quite
a bit.
George RR Martin also said that the 8th and
final season of the HBO hit was “not completely
faithful”
to the plot he has planned.
“Otherwise, the show would have to run another
five seasons” he said.
What all of this means is that the ending
and fates of most of the key characters will
be the same,
Dany will descend into madness, Bran will
become the King,
but it's the journey to this point that will
be entirely different.
Pacing, buildup, characters, everything up
until the end will be quite different.
Before this revelation from D&D came out,
I said in my season 8 episode 6 review video
that I don’t think the ending is necessarily
bad as in fact it’s how George RR Martin’s
books will also end as they said multiple
times that the ending will be the same, but
the journey to get there will be quite different,
and the journey is exactly what was so disappointing
in the show.
Dany going mad, Bran becoming the King, and
everything else could have been written so
that all of this would make sense.
Instead, we got rushed and poorly written
season
where the ending is nowhere near bittersweet,
only bitter.
I have no doubt that George RR Martin will
make all of this make sense,
and most importantly it won't be rushed.
"Who has a better story than Bran the Broken?"
Tyrion says, and for some reason, everyone
accepts it as a valid argument and they proclaim
Bran the King.
Why would they do that?
He has no better claim than anyone else, he
doesn't even have the best story among them,
and he did nothing of great significance in
the war against the Night King.
More like Bran the Useless.
The reasoning seemed weak, and the lack of
set-up is apparent.
What this shows us is that D&D knew they had
to make Bran the King,
but had no idea how to make it happen, had
no idea how to write his stories,
had no idea how to make him one of the most
important characters in the show,
which is why Bran was not even present throughout
the entire season 5,
and which is ultimately why the ending was
bad.
They failed to deliver Bran's journey to becoming
the King.
To talk about Bran's journey in the books
and how will he become one of the most important
characters, we firstly need to understand
George RR Martin's mind.
Every important character and event Martin
writes is based on the actual history,
from real events to myths and legends.
The entire A Song of Ice and Fire is inspired
by the Wars of the Roses, a series of English
civil wars for control of the throne.
The houses and characters from those wars
are what inspired most houses and characters
in Game of Thrones.
Most of the characters have their historical
equivalent.
Some of the most shocking moments in TV history
such as the Red Wedding
has historical parallels as well.
Even some of the most epic battles are inspired
by real historical battles
such as the Battle of Blackwater which is
based on the second Arab siege of Constantinopole
where Greek Fire was used to repel the invaders
as it could remain lit on water,
just like wildfire was used.
So now that we know George RR Martin uses
historical characters, events, myths, and
legends to inspire his own events and characters,
we need to ask ourselves, on who is Bran Stark
based.
Surely, the most important Martin's character
must be based on someone or something as most
other things are.
Well, some fans might have guessed it right.
Bran is most likely based on the Fisher King
also known as the Wounded King
because much like Bran, a known warrior wounded
him and he is unable to father next generation
to carry on after his death, which is one
of the main points Bran was chosen, King.
To make things even more interesting, in Celtic
mythology the Fisher King is derived from
the figure of Bran the Blessed, and the name
Bran in Welsh is usually translated as crow
or raven,
which oddly matches with Bran and him being
the Three-Eyed Raven.
George RR Martin once said that a fan theory
got the ending right
and few fans became confident that they now
know which one it is.
Bran as The Fisher King.
It's a story in which the king is wounded
and then blessed by divine power.
The Fisher King is the last in a long bloodline
charged with keeping the Holy Grail
much like Bran is charged by the Three-Eyed
Raven from the very beginning
by appearing in his dreams as a raven to come
to him,
become him and keep the power of the Three-Eyed
Raven.
On his way to the Holy Land to find the Holy
Grail, Fisher King was encountered by Three
Knights.
Bran Stark on his way to find the Three-Eyed
Raven is encountered by three threats as well;
- firstly by the wildlings where he had to
warg Hodor and the Direwolves to avoid being
found and killed,
- then he encountered the men of the Night's
Watch at Craster's Keep
where he was captured but managed to escape
- and finally, for the third time, he was
encountered by wights in front of the three-eyed
raven's cave who were placed there for one
purpose and it's to prevent him from entering
it
and becoming the Three-Eyed Raven.
As I already said, the Fisher King has many
similarities with Bran,
from characters itself to their fates and
journey, and names and nicknames
Bran Stark was always supposed to be the King.
He's the only type of monarch George RR Martins
sees fit to rule,
the kind where the king suffers on his journey
and is almost de-humanized for the sake of
his people.
In the show, Bran rules from the Red Keep,
yet the Iron Throne is destroyed.
In the books, it's most likely that Bran will
rule from Harrenhal,
and the Great Council where they choose the
King will take place not at the Dragonpit,
but at Harrenhal.
This makes far more sense in the books given
the significance of Harrenhal's succession
and lordship.
It was here where the previous Great Council
was held
when all the lords chose and voted for the
Targaryen successor
when King Jaehaerys l Targaryen wasn't certain
who his successor should be.
Harrenhal is located on the shore of the Gods
Eye,
the largest lake where the pact between the
First Men
and the children of the forest was signed
on the Isle of Faces.
Harrenhal is also centrally located, being
in the middle of Westeros,
so I think Bran will rule from Harrenhall,
not Kings Landing.
One of the big differences George RR Martin
will make that will lead to Bran becoming
the king,
is Bran playing the biggest role in defeating
White Walkers.
The Long Night was not really long in the
show, it lasted only one night.
Bran Stark didn't showcase any of his powers.
Have no doubt, the books will deliver on the
horrors that were set up,
and the White Walkers won't be defeated in
a single night.
The Long Night in the books is the event that
will completely change everything.
The Others, the Dragons, Greenseers and Skinchangers,
Red Priests,
Faceless Men and undead of all types... we
will see them all play a big role.
How will it lead to Bran the Broken?
Well, Bran will play the biggest role in defeating
the White Walkers, and I believe that will
win him the throne.
There is one interesting quote Stannis gives
to Jon Snow in the books.
Stannis says: ''Lord Seaworth is a man of
humble birth,
but he reminded me of my duty when all I could
think of was my rights.
I had the cart before the horse, Davos said.
I was trying to win the throne to save the
kingdom,
when I should have been trying to save the
kingdom to win the throne.''
George RR Martin did set this logic of true
King being the one who saves his people,
and what better king than Bran who saves the
realm from the Long Night.
After the War for the Dawn, people will look
at those who saved them as their new leaders.
I believe Dany will descend into madness and
die, but the books will do it much better
than the show did.
I believe Jon, who will be another hero of
the Long night,
will be offered to be the King on the Great
Council
on the grounds of him being, not only a hero
but the one with the best claim,
but he will refuse just like his great-great-uncle
Aemon Targaryen did,
and will go far north removing himself from
political court.
The only and the most important hero left
will be Bran the Broken
and he will be chosen the King after a long
council.
All in all, I believe the books will make
Bran's journey to becoming the king satisfying
and more importantly, I believe there will
be clues and hints pointing towards it,
while the show gave us only a few that most
of viewers probably didn't even notice.
One particular moment in the pilot seems significant
in retrospect.
The camera cuts to young Bran during Ned Stark's
recitation of the execution oath.
Just as Ned says the line, ''In the name of
Robert of the House Baratheon,
the First of His Name, King of the Andals
and the First Men...''
Camera cuts to Bran whom Jon tells not to
look away.
It seems they left it purposely unclear whether
we should focus on Bran or Jon in that shot.
That's a tactic the show often uses to subvert
our expectations.
For example, after Hardhome, it seemed that
the Night King was after Jon,
when in fact it was Bran that he really wanted.
It seems significant that Bran is also the
first person we see targeted by Jaime Lannister,
the man infamously known as 'Kingslayer.',
trying to slay this King before he even becomes
one.
Tyrion approaches Bran in season 8 episode
4 at the victory celebration following the
Battle of Winterfell.
He compliments Bran's wheelchair,
saying it's even better than the saddle he
designed back in season one.
According to Bran, his chair is based on the
one Daeron Targaryen built for his nephew
120 years ago.
Bran is talking about Daeron ll Targaryen
knows as Daeron the Good.
He made the wheelchair for his sister Daenerys
Targaryen’s crippled son.
His familiarity with that history impresses
Tyrion,
who told Joffrey back in season 4 that Daeron's
story
should be required reading for any future
ruler.
Quote: "The Lives of the Four Kings," Grand
Maester Kaeth's history of the reigns of Daeron
the Young Dragon, Baelor the Blessed, Aegon
the Unworthy, and Daeron the Good.
A book every king should read.''
In conclusion, the Game of Thrones showrunners
confirmed that George RR Martin's books will
end the same, especially the Bran becoming
the King part.
However, this doesn't mean we will be left
bitter and disappointed.
Just because the show failed to deliver a
satisfying journey towards this ending.
Dany going mad, Bran becoming the King, and
everything else could have been written
so that all of this would make sense instead
of being rushed, poorly written and bitter.
I have no doubt that George RR Martin will
make all of this make sense, give Bran Stark
a good story,
a good journey and make him useful and make
him the most important character in the Long
Night.
I believe we will get a satisfying and bittersweet
ending in the books,
and I really look forward to Bran Stark's
story.